c'est un geste qu'il répète des dizaines
de fois chaque jour
oussama essaie d'appeler sa femme mais
il n'y arrive souvent pas de râler sur
seulement ici c'est la turquie est là
bas c'est la syrie où ça m'habite
istanbul depuis neuf ans avec son frère
et dalal son épouse n'a jamais pu le
rejoindre et les coincés dans un camp
près d'idlib avec les jeunes frères et
soeurs de son mari dix ans de guerre en
syrie ça ressemble beaucoup à la famille
d'oussama
c'est un deuil qui n'en finit jamais à
l'image du conflit qui s'éternise le
deuil de ce qu'on a bâti des êtres chers
emprisonnés dont on est sans nouvelles
de ses morts qu'on enterre par groupe
c'est le deuil d'une perspective
d'avenir william marois b36 signer alors
que laurent bio ces histoires se
racontent dans un éco macabre de part et
d'autre d'une frontière qui ne se
traversent plus si facilement votre
héroïne ces jeunes hommes et de la
cherté 1.3 et or aujourd'hui les combats
en syrie ont presque cessé
machar al assad est toujours à la tête
du pays au sud alors colo colo mais ce
n'est pas une victoire et ce n'est pas
la paix
la syrie est en lambeaux les aspirations
de ceux qui se sont soulevés il ya dix
ans aussi
it was great ocean 2 m
bringing down vo ans est vrai que les
trithoises des baisses dramatiques et à
69 5 1 doit redevenir croisement
equipment tout d'élèves of de problème
emmanuel auger
on aurait pourtant pu croire à une
victoire de l'opposition mais selon anas
abdah l'occident s'est désolidarisé
alors qu'aux premières années du conflit
la planète quasi entière donné
l'impression d'être ligués contre bachar
el-assad
puis les choses sont devenues très
compliquées step by step des mines
original mais tout pas en top 14
un totem de friggit parallèlement à la
lutte contre le groupe etat islamique le
vent a tourné pour le régime syrien les
zones tenues par la rébellion sont
tombées les unes après les autres
soutenu par ses alliés russe les milice
chiite pro iranienne et l'armée
régulière syrienne le régime de bachar
al assad a repris ce qui constitue la
syrie utile le poumon économique du pays
[Musique]
avec chaque vague de bombardements et de
famine provoquée par les sièges leur sac
de nouveau flot de réfugiés et de
déplacés
comme ici en turquie abraham al-malki
avait 15 ans début de la révolte
populaire en 2011
[Musique]
il s'est accroché à l'idée d'une série
plus libres et démocratiques avec sa
famille tant qu'ils ont pu mais après la
chute d'alep en 2016 où ils s'étaient
déplacés il ne leur restait plus que
l'exil pour garder ce point et venir
[Musique]
indique aux montagnes à forte population
to be placed et houston calpine barre
des 10
aujourd'hui les défenseurs des droits de
l'homme croule sous la documentation des
crimes commis en dix ans de guerre
vidéos photos témoignages et lettres
officielles
si ça n'a pas suffi à faire cesser la
guerre c'est aujourd'hui malgré tout une
source d'espoir qu'une certaine justice
est encore possible mais documents
d'époque sauf des kings l'assemblée tout
régime un des trois actes canada john
inch nails industry garde éclairée
important president of writing d'origine
sont tous des tennis cette vision
optimiste des choses et peut être rendue
possible par l'éloignement du terrain de
l'opposition politique et dans les
tentes où s'abritent encore les syriens
on trouve bien peu de raisons d'y croire
kim kye-gwan tiguipko barque shenzhen
mais rien ne semble pouvoir succéder à
la désolation totale qui devenu la syrie
un scrutin présidentiel est prévu au
printemps
on en connaît ni la date ni les
candidats mais il fait peu de doute que
bachar al-assad devrait en retirer un
nouveau mandat de sept ans les dix
dernières années ne leur ont pas
convaincus que la syrie ne lui
appartient pas
pékin va là